foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
so I was on call in our respiratory ICU
one evening in 2019 when I got a call
from our emergency department
there was a young man I'll call him Ben
who came in short of breath
his lungs were full of fluid and
inflammation he didn't have enough
oxygen and could not breathe
he needed a breathing tube and a
ventilator to keep him alive
Ben like this young woman was one of
several hundred young people that came
to our hospitals in icus that fall and
summer of 2019.
he had been fine until a few days before
he developed a little bit of nausea some
belly pain then a fever then a dry cough
until he became so short of breath he
came to our Hospital
Ben like this one woman were part of a
group that had a mysterious illness
where we had no idea what was causing
their disease Ben had been healthy he
wasn't even a smoker he did Vape he
didn't think the vaping made his
breathing any worse so he had kept
vaping up until he came to the hospital
as the week wore on we did tests after
Dustin had a growing list of things that
we knew this disease wasn't but still
were not clear on what was causing Ben's
illness
Ben like this young woman had vaping
Associated lung injury
and if you think back to 2019 vaping was
being sold as this hip cool thing to
young people with lots of cool flavors
and the safe alternative to smoking to
older people and this was really the
first time we recognized on a broad
scale that vaping was dangerous
as Ben and others like him recovered we
wanted to know whether they went back to
normal
we warned the public about the risks of
vaping we shared our treatment protocols
with doctors and hospitals around the
world
and we found out that people didn't go
back to normal so they reported things
like cognitive impairment things like
difficulty thinking remembering or
making decisions
they had problems breathing shortness of
breath with walking or climbing upstairs
and some even reported problems with
dressing or bathing
these were young people who had suffered
a really serious serious and
life-threatening complication from
vaping were they able to quit we asked
and most had tried and most had been
able to cut down but only 38 percent
were able to quit all vaping and smoking
completely
did they change their vaping behavior in
other ways we asked yes
they changed their dealer yes dealer
they quit vaping and started smoking
instead
they cut back on vaping but we're still
vaping every day
overall they said they were being
smarter about it
meanwhile the rates of vaping among
teenagers kids in middle and high school
continued to rise
I asked my kids all in middle school at
the time whether they knew of any kids
in their school who Vaped and they all
said yes
but don't worry Mom Sam told me if
you're a seventh grader and you vape
you're not just going out and buying it
there's a friend or a brother or a
cousin or someone getting it for you
and it dawned on me that vaping like so
many other problems is not just a
problem of personal responsibility or
choice
it's a problem of a community and a
network
a network that exposes children to
vaping and exposure so risky and
addictive that even after people have
had the most severe life-threatening
consequence they're largely unable to
quit
and then it was March of 2020.
the grocery store shelves were empty
nobody had toilet paper kids were sent
home from school
people were sent home from work and
boundaries between home and work life
evaporated
some of us were called to the bedside to
take care of patients and we came
we risked our own lives and the lives of
our families to help others
and our community supported us people
sent us cards kind words food
we asked them to stay home to socially
distance to wear masks
and they largely did
and for all that hard work and sacrifice
we had some great success
people that had been in our icus for
months on the brink of death
came home to their families and their
communities
and by that December when we were giving
out the first coveted vaccines there was
real joy and relief in the air
we had shown up and taken care of people
our community had supported us
scientists had developed vaccines that
were safe and effective at incredible
speed
covet was over
except it wasn't
and over the next several years we
learned again and again
what had always been true
that the health of every one of us
depends on the health of all of us
that
covet is a disease not only of an
individual but also of a community
early on we saw a community of people
that lived in nursing homes
but we saw another group too these were
young people who were essential workers
whose jobs could not be done remotely
later on we saw another group well after
vaccines and masks were widely available
and recommended
these were people that were unvaccinated
in their 30s and 40s dying of covid
while they denied its existence
like this young woman Ben recovered from
his vaping Associated lung injury and I
saw him in clinic a few months later
he had been able to quit vaping
initially but with the social isolation
and stress from the pandemic
he had started again
he got covered and had to come back to
the hospital
but he survived and when I saw him he
had been able to quit vaping with the
support of his girlfriend and his family
so where do we go from here
we need to rebuild what did we learn it
was like we learned that some days our
paradise and others we just have to show
up and hope we're good enough
we learned that everything is political
Health Care science and education
we learned that no man is an island that
resilience and health rest within an
individual and a community
we learned that ventilators don't take
care of people people take care of
people
and perhaps most importantly
we learned that social isolation may be
worse than coven
we saw older patients dying from the
isolation meant to protect them
and we saw children never a group at
highest risk from covet itself fill our
emergency departments and mental health
crises
where do we go from here
we rebuild community
we need to rebuild community in our
social lives and our work lives and in
our family lives
Gathering Together
being present with each other and joy
are not freely extras we get as a luxury
these are the things that make it worth
doing everything else we do
and so I ask you today to think about
where do you find and build community
and where do you find joy
thank you
[Music]